I've made a big mistake
this man is hiding in the shadows you
guys beat him at least see we're
supposed to because the timeline changed
I know in the future what happens to me
hey everybody its charlie they just
dropped a new preview for the flash
episode 1 we found out who the meta of
the week is and it's a huge easter egg
for Bart Allen in the comics making me
think that Nora is probably gonna be the
Bart Allen of the flash TV series
henceforth so I'll explain what's going
on we also got more details about
Sherlock wells the new version of
Harrison wells this season if you're new
to the channel there's a new round of
that flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video first big image
Barry and Nora fighting gridlock
remember he's wearing the season 1
costume it actually looks pretty shiny
in these images here these look pretty
polished he's wearing this because they
destroyed the season 4 costume when they
blew up that satellite that's why it was
all ripped up Nora has already
introduced herself and explained the
problem and everybody's still scratching
their heads but there's a minute the
sort of the call to action for them to
call the party short so that they can go
save someone and you actually get the
excitement of Nora teaming up officially
with her father remember she helped him
out during the season 4 finale but that
was kind of on the DL he didn't know
that it was happening you get a much
better look at her X s inspired costume
the reason why her emblem is really
small on her chest there and not really
big painted all the way down like it is
in the comics is because they use those
emblems to embed tech anything that they
might need to fight the villain of that
week so gridlock in the comics is
actually straight out of the impulse
title which is Bart Allen solo title
after they first introduced the
character the fact that they're calling
the episode Nora that's the title of
episode 1 and they're pulling from Bart
Allen for her very first outing
officially as part of team flash just
implies that she is always going to be
the Bart Allen of the series so that
means she's the combination of like
three four different characters Barry
and irises twins from the comics dawn
and Dawn both named on Jenny Ignatz
who's his granddaughter by his daughter
in the comics in Bart Allen who's his
grandson by his son in the comics so
that doesn't mean that they'll never do
those other characters but it just
implies that they're going to stick with
Nora as their young speedster from the
future so I'm just not expecting to see
Bart Allen pop up anytime soon or if he
does maybe it'll be on Titan's which is
set in a different universe
so it doesn't necessarily cross over
with these flash characters but in the
comics gridlock was a normal person that
was fired from his job as an urban
planner that later gained the ability to
steal kinetic energy from people so he
has the ability to steal speed from
Barry and Nora so I think that's also a
bit of a setup for cicadas powers which
is mostly killing metas but also taking
away their power or draining them of
their power like we're all thinking
about Cisco in the future so just
remember every year in episode 1 they
always lob you a softball explainer with
some other small villain for big
concepts that they use later on for much
bigger twist so really small tees here
negating or taking away Barry's speed in
the future cicada really taking away
people's powers in a big way because
that's why Norris said in that trailer
in the future originally before I mess
stuff up you guys were supposed to beat
cicada but now he beat you because of
something that I did so if it wasn't
clear the thing that she did was come
back into the past and interact with
these people fundamentally changing
their lives ripple effect butterfly
effect changing things down the road so
that they were not able to defeat cicada
you also see these pictures of Nora here
continuing to explain in that scene that
we saw during the trailer so I kind of
messed things up I'm not sure what to do
do you guys have any ideas and the rest
of team flash is just scratching their
heads like I love the look on Caitlin
and Cisco face like oh hell no the funny
thing about Nora in the first couple of
episodes is that she doesn't just live
with Barry and iris she hops around and
stays with different members of team
flash which I think they're just gonna
use for a little bit of comedy and it
sort of set up that tension plot that
she has with iris look she's not such a
big fan of iris so she tries to find
ways to go stay somewhere else so that
it's not so awkward for her until they
work through whatever drama that is we
meet the new Sherlock wells he's just
gonna be a detective that will help them
track down cicada so in the way that
they do at the beginning of every season
you get a teaser for the villain in the
first couple of episodes like cicada
pops up at all these places where
disasters are happening we see him
without his mask on here so that means
it will probably see him in broad
daylight eventually also just walking
around like a normal person and we won't
know who he is I mean we the audience
will know who he is
because he's being played by Chris Klein
but you can have a scene where iris West
walks by him on a sidewalk without
knowing that he's cicada or you can have
Barry not knowing that he's cicada the
weird thing about the IMDB for episode
one is it's also listing the new spin
character from the comics as being part
of the cast I don't know if this is
incorrect that's a character that can
actually make someone's worst fears come
to life but they're using them as a more
of a news reporter or social media
person in the context of the TV show so
maybe while iris is doing her blog
reporting about all these meta attacks
happening in the first couple of
episodes you also have this other news
person doing the same thing albeit she's
one of the medes that they have to take
down so maybe there's some plot where
she turns into a villain over the first
couple of episodes but then obviously
Nora gives him the flash ring we get the
new flash suit so the thing about this
is that most of the behind-the-scenes
pictures haven't done it that much
justice like this picture here were
they're teaming up together
it looks cool because they're teaming up
but it doesn't do the flash suit any
favors because they haven't tuned the
color up in post-production they haven't
lit it correctly so it's gonna look a
little bit shinier when we actually get
to the episode but a lot of you have
guessed correctly because she comes from
the future this is a future version of
this suit it's not ultimately the last
version of the suit that he wears
because the suit that he's wearing in
that future newspaper has a chin on it
so Grant Gustin has been teasing people
about when they're gonna get the chin
back there was the promo for the three
night crossover that they released where
he has the new costume on and it's still
chin 'less so I don't know if they were
just trying to avoid spoilers like oh we
don't want people to know that he's
getting the chin back or if he really
will go halfway through the season
before he gets that back I think part of
the idea for them trying to do this
version of the costume is is that it
looks better coming out of the flash
ring when they do the special effect
like look at the comic book version of
this it looks like very thin cloth so
they may have just decided in
post-production that it was easier to do
the flash ring special effect if the
physical suit looked a little bit more
like this
you guys all probably know what's going
on with arrow Titans is actually getting
its premiere at New York Comic Con I've
gotten screeners for the first three
episodes so I have watched the first one
so I already know what the pilot looks
like I'm under embargo I can't say
anything about that
until after the premiere so my
non-spoilery Titans episode 1 review
will post during New York Comic Con in a
couple weeks and then a couple weeks
after that is when the official premiere
is when everybody gets to watch
everything so without giving anything
away some of the things that people were
complaining about after seeing the
Titans series are incorrect the trailer
is very misleading in the way it
presents the series some of the things
ended up being very different so I'll
explain all that stuff after the
embargoes up no worries but September
15th is when the beta officially opens
for DC's streaming service and for those
of you asking about international
countries I've heard both Netflix as a
solution for where episodes will go and
also international versions of the
streaming platform so hopefully they'll
reveal more details about that later
this year but don't worry they will find
a way for you to be able to watch the
series there in the middle of casting
swampthing right now - they said that
it's gonna be a hard-r horror series so
if you've been waiting for hardcore
swamp thing it sounds like it's gonna be
pretty cool but we probably won't see a
preview for that till sometime next year
it just a reminder Young Justice season
3 is premiering in January sometime
we'll get a more specific date when we
get a little bit closer so no worries
about that but what'll happen is is I'll
name a new giveaway winner when I post
new DC click here for my New Avengers
phase 4 video and click here to rewatch
that last big flash trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]